the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
[Applause]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be how marvel's eternals
movie is helping set up the core x-men
characters and mutants in the mcu
explain how they can just suddenly start
showing up in the next few years before
the new x-men solo movie that kevin
feige has said that they're working on
and they'll be adults there's a deep
connection between the eternals the
x-men characters just in general that
goes back to their origin story and the
eternals trailer references some of
those plot elements so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there'll be a lot more
eternals footage that'll start releasing
after the shangshi movie comes out
during my big eternals trailer videos
and easter eggs that i posted the last
couple of days i explained how some of
the major conflicts of the eternals
movie are basically the hulk's infinity
gauntlet snap during avengers end game
bringing everyone back in the universe
unleashes such a massive amount of
cosmic energy that it was enough to
complete the maturation process of this
new celestial that's growing inside
planet earth the emergence that they're
referring to during the trailer footage
a new eternal emerging from its
celestial cocoon that's what this huge
structure cersei is looking at is in the
trailer there's a scene that looks like
the meteorite crashing to earth when
salma hayek's ajax character is
explaining this to icarus and they show
you the origin of the mcu the big bang
all the other celestials being created
by eternity in the moments after the big
bang that's what this scene is the
meteorite sounds like it's the celestial
egg so to speak crashing to earth to
begin its gestation process over
millions of years while that's happening
it slowly absorbs background cosmic
radiation cosmic radiation like the kind
scarlet witch uses to power her chaos
magic the same type of energy the
infinity stones give up the same energy
that was present at the big bang when
the other celestials were created and
this new celestial just grows and grows
until it eventually becomes larger like
the other members of the celestial host
that we see in the trailer like irishman
the judge in jamaica the analyzer they
are massive and super powerful so it
just takes a long long ass time for them
to grow the only way to accelerate that
process is to just feed them more
background cosmic energy from the
infinity stones so this is where we get
to our connection between what's
happening here mutants and the core
x-men characters mutants are a little
bit different in the mcu and in order to
be considered a mutant you need to be
born with your powers and typically you
have to be able to express your power
generate your power from your own body
in some way your genetic code has to
fundamentally be different in some way
than regular humans they reference some
of this during wand division like monica
rambo's genetic code gets rewritten
basically mutates her dna by passing
through the hex so many different times
there was a lot of talk on one division
about whether or not billy and tommy
were the first true mutants in the mcu
or if scarlet witch and quicksilver
qualified as the first mutants because
both of them were born with their powers
and the mind stone just unlocked scarlet
witch's full potential but she was
already born with her chaos magic
abilities technically that does qualify
her as a mutant the only reason why the
mcu movies didn't acknowledge that
earlier was because of the legal rights
issue with fox in real life controlling
the x-men characters and marvel not
being able to use the term mutant in any
of its movies until they bought fox in
2019 but regardless of that billy and
tommy are still both mutants in the mcu
scarlet witch used her chaos magic to
create them to create two new mutants
and here's the connection between what
she did with chaos magic and the
celestial that's growing inside the
cosmic egg that we see during the
eternals trailer it's feeding on the
same background cosmic radiation the
infinity stones from the snaps in the
same energy that wanda was using to
power her chaos magic when she was
changing everything inside the hex the
same energy that was given off by the
big bang that eternity used to create
the original celestial host like airshim
the judge here the difference during the
big bang though is that there was so
much of that energy present that it was
enough to create many celestials and
they're just way less of that energy at
this point in history when they're
trying to mature this new celestial then
sort of bringing it back around a wand
division connecting this it's all
connected the producers of wand division
said that in the mcu the way they're
explaining chaos magic that it is magic
of pure creation so when you talk about
mutants in the mcu the eternals movie is
kind of doing something similar to what
wanda was doing on one division
explaining how the growing celestial
absorbs all this cosmic radiation over
time but in turn while that's happening
it also gives off cosmic radiation like
celestials are super powerful even one
that's growing it is bursting with the
same kind of cosmic energy that the
infinity stones give off and while
that's happening during human evolution
the cosmic radiation that the celestial
is giving off inside earth slowly starts
mutating humans dna to create the x gene
they got into this idea in the comics
which is a slightly different explainer
it was celestial blood instead of just
background cosmic radiation so what
they're doing during the eternals movie
is extremely similar to the comic book
explainer but fast forward to present
day you theoretically have many people
all over the earth randomly with the x
gene but up to present day in most cases
the x gene has been dormant explaining
why you haven't seen reports of tons of
teenagers running around shooting lasers
out of their eyes this is also the same
way that you can explain older mutants
like apocalypse or even wolverine have
been around this whole time because
wolverine was born in 1832 in the comics
he's almost 170 years old during the
events of the first x-men movie this
celestial's eternals explainer makes it
really easy to say that some of these
mutants powers did manifest across
history like there were actual mutants
around but those individuals either were
able to stay off the radar or their
existence was kept secret by powerful
people in the mcu it's all a giant
conspiracy they even got into this idea
recently in the comics with a big x-men
reboot professor x for instance most
powerful telepath on planet earth during
that storyline professor x learns that
they're stuck in a time loop like we
talk about kang the multiverse war he
who remains in the time loop of the
sacred timeline professor x learns about
this and learns that mutants x-men are
always destined to die out to be killed
off so he calls an audible and says
we're changing the game and he basically
removes memory of mutants from
everyone's minds on planet earth so that
nobody knows they exist but in the mcu
at the end of the day the answer is
still the same mutants for instance have
always been here we just haven't known
about them till now it's the exact same
explainer for the eternals characters
they've been here this whole time but
this is why we haven't known about them
till now and it's all because of what
happened with avengers infinity war
avengers end game in the snaps is the
same thing they did in the early marvel
phases after the first avengers movie
came out they used the plot from
avengers with the shatari invasion and
how that affected earth as the basis for
a lot of the plot of the future movies
like the reason why iron man
inadvertently winds up leading to the
creation of ultron was because of what
happened with the chitauri invasion
anybody remember when i carried a nuke
through a wormhole no it's never come up
save new york never heard that recall
that so a lot of the big twists of
marvel phase four are built on the backs
of all these infinity gauntlet snaps
that happened the past couple of years
in avengers infinity war in avengers end
game but all this cosmic energy is
unleashed activating people's x genes
across planet earth so that in the next
couple of years you start to hear more
reports of people running around with
weird powers now that's just one way
that they'll probably explain mutants
and x-men in the mcu because the
multiverse is such a huge storytelling
trope that they're leaning into some of
these new major characters will also
probably come from alternate universes
which gets into the events of loki the
kang multiverse war doctor strange two
multiverse of madis even spiderman no
way home and even though it's a little
further off ant-man 3 quantum mania all
those movies will be the next step in
revealing mutants x-men characters and
actually we should also now add black
panther to wakanda forever to that list
because of what they're doing
introducing namor and the atlanteans to
the mcu and he will have been here this
whole time but there is a cool
connection between king the conqueror
who we just saw on loki and apocalypse
kang's first appearance in the comics
was as rama tut so in fantastic four
number 19 he travels back to ancient
egypt sets himself up as a pharaoh calls
himself ramatud but eventually once he
gets bored with that decides to go to a
different time period he sets up
apocalypse as his successor that's also
why they included the great sphinx and
the great pyramid easter eggs during
loki episode 5 just as a reference to
that part of kang's history just in
terms of that new x-men movie coming out
kevin feige has said that they haven't
cast any of the new core x-men
characters like wolverine yet but given
all the movies that they've already
announced including deadpool 3 and
avengers 5 which kevin feige just
confirmed this past week they've got so
many movies coming out that they
wouldn't be able to release the new
x-men movie before 2024 so what's
probably going to wind up happening is
that they'll just use the next avengers
movie avengers 5 as a sort of focal
point to set the stage for the new x-men
solo movie like both those movies will
happen around the same time and they'll
be heavily connected but by that time
we'll probably have met at least a
couple of the core x-men characters in
other people's big movies i know there's
all kinds of questions about legacy
actors coming back like will hugh
jackman ever come back as a version of
old man logan wolverine will patrick
stewart ever come back most of them are
saying no like hugh jackman has even
gone as far to say that kevin feige has
not contacted him about coming back
which i do not believe at all i do
believe that there's been some
discussion behind the scenes about
finding a way to have him cameo in some
future project but when they do get up
to a new version of wolverine in the mcu
it will be a new actor like the new main
version of wolverine will be somebody
different i have a feeling they'll let
ryan reynolds deadpool character just
joke a lot about that kind of stuff when
we get to the new deadpool movies in the
mcu so everyone let me know in the
comments what kind of easter eggs for
mutants are you hoping to see in the
eternals movie i know everyone's hoping
for a galactus post-credit scene of some
kind since there are so many celestials
and big cosmic characters in that movie
i'm not expecting a ton of galactus
easter eggs until they release their new
fantastic four movie which sounds like
right now is going to be released during
2023 at some point we'll see that a long
time before we see the new x-men movie
but there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up in the next couple of weeks
i'll be doing some more shangshi videos
once that movie comes out my what if
episode 3 video will post on wednesday
just like normal and there are even
rumors that a spiderman no way home
trailer might get released next week but
i wouldn't hold your breath on that one
so if we get any kind of spiderman
footage of course i will do a whole
bunch of videos about it everyone click
here for my full eternals trailer
breakdown in easter eggs and click here
for my other new eternals video and
footage thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you